Good. So let's start our last uh topic
of this of this course and this will be
called
recursive estimation.
The whole idea and the whole question is
we have our plant process or system or
whatever of which we have uh we have
understood in in some way let's say if
we uh if we conducted an experiment we
selected some independent variables
their their values we got the true
response
of this of this system of this of this
plant. And
uh we tried based on what we have seen
in the experiments, we try to find out
some model that could predict this
historical data. Of course, well,
predicting historical data is fine, but
not not uh that much useful all the
time. So uh we hope that if we just uh
just try to now unroll and uh
uh deploy this model in some industry.
This model can can now tell us what's
going to happen with the plan with its
outputs if we are now trying whatever
whatever inputs whatever values of the
of the independent variables.
Um basically we we hope that even at
some points in the in the future where
if we if we compare these so if we
calculate something like estimation
error then this will be approximately
approximately
zero estimate. Now let's let's call it
prediction
error. What if this this will this will
not happen? And uh let's start with a
with a very very basic situation. I
don't know exactly how to how to draw
it, but well, let's let's
say let's say that our historical data
might have looked like like this.
and uh
our our model our our our fit. This is
this is what we this is what we got. And
maybe there is a there is some
uh some part of
the of the of the of the space of our
independent variables that was not uh
explored in in in our training
data. But in the in the reality maybe
our our plant would would evolve like
this. So we had something like a like a
systematic error. We it might be uh
consequence of the of the plant being
being nonlinear that uh suddenly
our our real measurements are saying
well we have we have some some constant
almost constant
error. Yeah. So let's say this was
our
our training part or we can even say it
was our our nominal part. Yeah.
Nominal because uh so we are either
um either we either have some deviation
from the from the nominal uh nominal
situation. Let's say we were producing
in our in our plant in our industry from
one supplier of the reactants and now we
change the supplier and there is there
is some some change which which causes
also our our plant to
change. But this situation doesn't look
very very uh scary or
very very very very tough to fix because
well our error looks almost uh almost
constant. It's
approximately approximately constant. So
what would you what would you say? Let's
say our our model looks like
this. How can we what can we what can we
try to to fix our model to to adapt to
the new situation?
We add minus error to minus the error.
Uh yeah. So
the error. Mhm. Mhm. Yep. our model was
uh was calculated this uh these
parameters A and B were basically
calculated from the from the historical
historical data and from how I
suggestively uh draw it uh it seems that
the that the slope is actually quite
okay. Yeah, still still our uh dependent
variable still react
uh still react in a reacts in the in the
same same fashion to the to the change
of the of the independent uh variable in
this testing
or I don't know real
time real time deployment
So our slope is good. We cannot change
our independent variables. We can
somehow try to try to alter well this
constant this uh offset or or this or
this bias to accommodate for the for the
constant shift in the in the error.
So for the this B will have a different
different names but uh for the purpose
of our our discussion the very um very
first type
of very first type of recursive
estimation that we can do is just to
just to change this this bias and
This is called bias
[Music]
update very much in in use uh in the in
the industry.
Uh they they wouldn't if they use some
model of of this type, they wouldn't
like to to change uh change the the
slopes the dependencies because well
let's say they were they are verified.
But uh yeah, if we if we should should
change the
bias, how how can we how can we we
approach this? Uh let's say that
our let's
say that
our our model predictions independent
variables and also this this parameter
well since we are changing it it it
becomes now a function function of
time. So what we can what we can easily
easily do is
uh how to how to fix this one? Um we can
for
example basically say that this uh that
this BK would always always react
to what we have seen in the past and
what what we have what we have predicted
in the
past. Yeah.
So basically we are we are removing
removing the the error that that we have
that we have seen. Let's see how it how
it goes in the past. Okay. Minus
[Music]
one
-
ax ax k - one. Yeah, this
could this could work. Ah, no,
sorry. We took a
measurement. Let me rewrite it
again. How was our error defined?
Y K
minus Y
K Y K
hat. No, this wouldn't work,
right? We need to derive it in a in a
different fashion. I mean, I can write
it down, but it won't won't make make
sense to you.
Uh so let's say we used uh we used this
uh this
prediction for the previous previous
[Music]
measurement. Okay. Minus one. And uh
well what we really really measured was
was this value. So this was our our true
true measurement. Well, and now we now
we now we want to compare may make a
comparison of these two and update and
update here. This is not a mistake.
Update update here the bias such that
such that it it would
work.
So we take we take these two and and
update.
Uh so if we just if we just subtract
everything we
get yk -1 - y k -1 that's on the left
hand
side. on the right hand side. Of course
these two these two will will cancel and
we have
B B B B B B B B B B B B B B B B B B B B
B K K K K K K K K K K K K K K K K K K K
K K K -1
-
BK which of course means that BK should
be equal to to what?
So our previous previous bias let's just
take the minus bk on the right hand side
and we we take
our our prediction
error to the to the left hand side. Huh?
Makes sense. So, uh this is basically a
very very simple very simple mechanism
that will that will make
us what what will it what will it do?
So
our former prediction that was this that
was this uh this blue line uh is now at
some point wrong. If we just change
change the bias at at some point we can
just
achieve just achieve this this shift. Of
course you can ask what happens if we
then do not predict the next uh point in
time the this the same value. Uh what if
the error in the prediction is just
caused by some by some noise. Uh so
there are different different nuances to
it. So this is our fixed prediction with
this bias formula. Uh what people always
uh always suggest
is well this is kind of this is kind of
meopic. It it gets uh really driven fast
to change this one based on just one
point in time just one one measurement.
So uh we
can we can alter it with some with some
filtering
filter and this filtering is just very
very
easy. So the new BK will be
some let's call it
delta BK - 1
- 1 - delta
oops one minus delta and this value of
the of the prediction
error where this delta is something
between between zero and
one. Basically you are you are saying uh
by choosing the the delta what would
happen if we choose delta to be to be
close to one then we are basically
saying we do not trust our measurements
uh that much we are we are not going to
uh change our our bias that much based
on the based on the recent measurements
but if this trend would continue yeah if
we really see uh situation situation
like like this happening in our data.
Then this small contribution from each
measurement they would they would add up
and our our line would be just gradually
slowly slowly shifting to the possibly
new operating point, possibly new new
situation. Of course vice versa. If this
is if this is zero then we just we are
just uh drawn completely by the by the
new new
measurement. So you can think about this
this delta as something as a as a gain.
Yeah. How much do I do I trust the the
information from the from the
measurements? Yeah. If you if you think
about this, this is something similar
[Music]
to let's say some some P controller.
What is
[Music]
the one way to to represent the
proportional proportional
controller? We have
a we have a control
error. Control error like here we have
the the prediction error.
We multiply it with some with some
gain. And this is how we how we change
our estimate of a control action. This
is how we how we change the estimate of
our of our
[Music]
model. Very very simple uh but used in
the in the in the in the practice.
Let's uh let's now see a see a different
different
situation. So of course well since we
since we had a situation where we only
need to change the change the bias and
everything everything started to work.
Now we will check the situation. What if
uh what if we need
to really
change change some of the of the
dependencies. Yeah. So something very
very similar similar
setup. We fit our model and now at some
point our data start to start to behave
like like this. So what what we can
think of of a
mechanism basically what we
are what we are doing sometimes you will
find this uh
drawn as uh well
we calculate
oops
we calculate our prediction error. So
this is our our
E and
our update mechanism is
just updating the model. Yeah, this is
how you can somehow f sometimes find it
uh
represented. It's uh also used in in
things like adaptive control. Somebody
know
So let's think about the model just in
just in this form because we somehow
intuitively feel that we we should we
should at some point try to change the
the
slope. Um and let's
uh think about the situation.
Uh well, we just we have just seen n
minus one
measurements or we have just
seen n measurements.
Um this was the one of the simplest uh
situations that we studied in our not
here in our linear regression
uh
discussion. Let me wind it
back. So if we
were if we were about
about
to this these are the wonderful sums
that you all remember and loved uh that
we formulated in the linear regression
problem. We have some data y that we
collected we have our independent data x
and uh to estimate estimate the value of
a. Well, basically we just need to solve
this equation. We already made this made
this part with with B equal to equal to
zero. Did we find some better
expression? No. Uh what will be the
value of A
equal equal
here? Is it correct? Yes.
How can we find
the value of a? It's just a scalar.
Sorry.
[Music]
Mhm. So yeah. So a will be equal
to the first part. Well, sum of y's,
right? Yes. Divided ending. No, that's
zero.
So the sum sum of y divided by sum of
x's.
Yeah. Okay.
Good. Yeah. So a and let's now call it
like a n like the again we will we will
give it some time index because we we
might change the parameters over the
time. So if we
have seen collected
uh n measurements k is equal to 1 to n.
How is it? Sum
of sum of y's divided by sum of
x's.
Okay.
And n minus one. Well, it will be almost
the same same situation. We just uh have
this
sum going
from k= 1 but not until n until n minus
one. We have one measurement one
measurement
less. Okay.
Let's write down this
properly sum of k = 1 until until
n and our task uh task now
is no if you if you look at these uh
they're not directly comparable but if
the n is like 100 yeah So most of our
most of the terms in the numerator
denominator are the are the same. Uh so
the question would be
uh question would be the following. Uh
it might not be if the end will will
grow. Uh it might not be even u
practical to uh to actually take all the
time thousand or million of the of the
historical historical values and just
solve solve this. Of course this is easy
situation. A is scalar but if we are in
the in the multi-dimensional world this
will lead to to some inversions of the
large matrices matrices. So nothing
nothing very very practical.
It uh
also might be the the case that well we
we would be able to discover this kind
of this kind of pattern, right? Because
here here here it was here it was cool.
Yeah, we just have the last value of the
of our parameter. we update it somehow
filtered or not with the with what what
is the what is the error and boom we
have our our new value of the of the
parameter so can
we need to check the procedure because I
don't don't remember it somehow somehow
make this
uh make this uh make this happen to have
like a update formula so like A n is
equal to a n minus one plus or minus
plus or minus something.
So what we can do what we can do first
well is to make this these sums to to
really uh
really really be equal to each other or
at least look equal to each other.
So of course if we have
this n elements of the sum n sums we can
always rewrite this as the sum
from k = 1 until n minus
one of y
k did we take correct
formula I have different in my
[Music]
notes.
Mhm. My notes say we should have this
formula. And why is that?
Why is it better to take that
one? I don't see any any big
difference. Let's see. Let's let's try
let's try in this in this
version. Okay. So our sum from 1 to n
can be the sum from 1 to n minus one.
And of course what we are what we are
missing is to is to
add the the last measurement y at at the
time n.
The same we can
do in
the
denominator. X K
+ X
N. So far so
good. But okay. Uh we can now
say we can now say what for example we
can take this sum
yk and substitute for for this
[Music]
one. So the
Sum of
y's is equal
to we take a n minus
one times the sum of x's
[Music]
Good. And let's try
to
take this
one, this expression, and let's let's
plug it plug it in here. Right. The
This sum is the same left left hand
side. So the right right hand side must
be
equal. All right. So we can plug it
in. A n is equal to what?
a n
-1 sum of x k = 1 n
-1. Yeah, that's the that's the thing in
the in the green green bubble. What we
are missing is to add the last
measurement of the
output
yn. And now
what? Still divided by
the sum of k =
1 x k + xn.
And what do we need to do now?
[Music]
Um
basically what what would be your idea
how we can how we can eliminate the a n
minus one from from here?
Sorry, this should be n minus
one. Like we can almost almost divide
this,
right?
Almost. But we only only have have this
term which
is messing messing up this plan. Divide
into some like into two sums there are
some together
divide well we can divide anything into
two sums. Yeah
sure. But we want we want this form.
Yeah, we we we basically want to want to
divide here by by this uh by this number
or it's better if we divide this by this
number and we we will get just the just
the parameter
a and y is uh a * x
y n is a *
x. Yes, but uh wait but a n times xn. So
that that that doesn't help. That was
that was that was a that was a good
thought good thought.
[Music]
Um well fake it till you make it, right?
So let's just
uh yeah this is sorry n min a n minus
[Music]
one. Yeah if if we just add this one
then we already in the numerator have a
n minus one times this sum plus a n
minus one plus this time x n. So, so we
can eliminate this go. Okay. So, if we
edit this thing, we need to also to make
it equal, we need to also subtract it,
right?
Okay. So now, now we can be already
already good to go.
So, we can now
definitely let's try
to we can
now get rid of this guy. Get rid of this
guy with the with the denominator and we
just separate our a n minus
one. Good. What we will be left with?
What we will be left
with is
uh so maybe let's just write it in the
in the special slightly special form. we
will have
uh let's just keep the numerator
denominator separated and we can write
write it write it back as a as a sum of
x's from k1 until until
n
and what is left is our measurement at
time
[Music]
n
and
basically - a n -1
xn
good looks Good. Looks good.
Uh there is uh what is this one? This
one here is the measurement that we have
just measured and we are and we are
correcting
our our parameter
A.
So okay something similar that we have
here. We should have plugged in the
plugged in the minus to to see it
better. And uh what is the what is the
other term? Well, this would be just our
our prediction. But what kind of
prediction is that? It's a prediction of
the old unupdated model. Yeah, we
already know at the time point n we have
this uh this value of x this value of
independent variables but we haven't
done this this update yet. We are just
just predicting this this
value. So this would be our
uh
predicted at time n and sometimes uh to
completely mess up the indices and
everything people would write it in in
this way. There will be like this pipe
and n minus one which would
mean prediction of the output at time n
based on the information I know until
the until the time n minus one. So I
haven't taken this this
measurement measurement
yet. But if I if I take if I take it
well, I will have a I will have a new
new
prediction. So updated value of the
parameter times times xn. Yeah. So this
will be
then prediction of n with the
information until the until the the
point with all the information until the
time point
n.
Okay, let's write it down.
Prediction.
[Music]
prediction
of y at time
point and based
on
information until
[Music]
the time point
n. Okay.
And this is basically how our how our
recursive estimation is now is now
working. Uh like like before what what
have we what have we studied? Basically
we have
our prediction error and we have some
some gain. This is how much we are going
to going to trust our our
measurement in updating our value of the
of the parameter. But this time it's
it's not like it it's doesn't seem to be
our our choice. what would what would
happen along along the along the time.
So let's say we are just starting with
using of our model. We are just starting
this recursive estimation. We just
measured first uh first x for uh for
simplicity let's just say it's it's one.
So we we just have here uh one as our
gain multiplying this this prediction
error. Okay. Now if we if we
now get
100 new measurements so 100 time points
passed let's say that our value of x
didn't didn't change at all. So it's one
one all the time we already have one one
over 100. So our gain is already already
much uh much smaller. We are already
saying well what happened the parameter
a n minus one it already had the
information of the n time points but one
so it's a if n is is large then it's a
lot of information we don't want this
information to be uh lost to to to get
lost just by one measurement where there
there might be possible some even some
noise in this in this output.
Of course, you might you might then then
ask uh how to how to cope with with this
kind of situation. Let's say you have 10
years of data and 10 years of data are
predicting some sort of a correlation
between the independent and dependent
variable. And well, you just have maybe
five measurements that are kind of
contradicting this uh previously
observed observed trend. Uh you
can very very easily
uh very easily uh limit
this limit this part. You can basically
say okay I'm not going to look at all
the possible past data. I just I just
take maybe last month last half a year.
It depends now it depends on the tuning
how much you know about your process how
much how much this
uh how much it can change. Okay. So this
is like
a
shortened time
[Music]
window. Shorten the time window.
for more recent updates.
[Music]
Okay. So this was the this was the the
part with uh how we can how we can
update the slopes or let's say a slope
because well we kind of assume that a is
a is a scalar. So the question is how
this works in the in the general general
situation. So in general this this used
to be our our prediction
model. Uh let's maybe also write it in
this way like the at end point in in
time this would look
oops something like this. If we
wanna if we want to update
our our parameters, this will be the
this will be the world we are we are
living
in. Um so let's just uh let's just write
write this down. The derivation is uh is
nice
but but uh it it takes takes some
time. So if we now use the same line of
thoughts like how much how we are how we
proceeded with the in our in our simpler
case. probably should recover
some similar sort of a of a update
update formula. So
our previous and now this is the vector
right that's why I started to write this
funny symbols here the scalar scalar
multiplication so our new vector of
parameters will be updated from the old
vector of parameters our
[Music]
gain now this
is I know let's write
V. And this will
be
the Now let's use something which we
which we quite know about
uh v
times xn
n times
what? Let me rewrite it because I wanted
to start wanted to first write it with a
shorthand notation
but just simplify
it xrpose x
inverse we have xn
And we have
our prediction error. So x transpose n
time
[Music]
p b p b p b p b p b p b p b p b p b p b
p n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n
n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n
n minus
one.
Um this is how how it would how it would
would look in a in a completely
completely general case. We still we
still have the the
same same ingredients. Yeah, there is
the prediction
error. Our
Sometimes it's called a priory
information, a priory knowledge about
the
[Music]
parameter and of
course and of course uh some gain. If
you observe this gain closely, well,
what we have here, we have here the
number of the historical values of of X.
Yeah, this is really those uh that
coariance coariance matrix
um and it's and it's inverse. So
something similar as if it was in the in
the in the denominator. So if the number
of uh of our past historical values of x
grows then also our our gain gets gets
smaller.
[Music]
Okay.
Good. That's basically that's basically
it.
Um, if we had more time and we never
have more time in this in this in this
course then uh well
like like we made this uh made this look
similar to our to our controller. we are
one step away from turning this into
into into a sort of a estimator of the
of the states. Yeah.
because also things like so let's say I
have x at time k is equal to
oops how should I write it now
x k -1 + b UK minus one plus what do you
use at the theory of automatic controls?
Maybe some some gain and you
take Y K
minus C
* C * X K. Yeah, some something like
this.
Um this is this is not nothing else. If
we choose our gain wise, for example,
there is the common gain, then then this
will this will
become then this will become
uh common
filter where well it's not estimating
estimating the parameter. is just
directly estimating the states of a of a
dynamic system. But still the idea
remains the same. Well, I have some
previous prediction. Yeah. From the from
the time point k minus one, I predict
what the x k would be. But well, I
measure measure something something else
about the about the the state xk. So I
use the update there is again this this
gain matrix. Yeah. So this is all in all
uh the the same
stuff.
Good. Any
questions does not seem to be the the
case.
[Music]